excusez moi je suis à vous génial
bonjour c'est ma maison se passe un truc
monsieur joyner le copain que vous avez
hébergé robert hue a indiqué rechercher
pour meurtres et trahisons il ya
actuellement en sa possession des
secrets d'état hautement confidentielles
qu'il voudrait céder à nos ennemis pour
vous permettez c'est quoi ce à quoi je
veux absolument tout savoir
tous les détails sur vos liens avec
l'agent stone l'agent stones bob votre
ami bob rester concentré s'il vous plaît
d'accord je crois qu'il ya un malentendu
non weir dic n'est pas moi même alors
pourquoi ils vous désigne comme persona
joindre en cas d'urgence sur tout nous
fichons c'est vrai c'est à peine si je
connais ce gars alors pourquoi il
dormait sur votre canapé parce qu'on est
sortis boire à verrières soit vous êtes
sortis boire un verre avec un inconnu
quoi ok et si on essayait de le brûler
thomas j j'appuie sur le bouton temps
mort c'est bon vous et vos collègues
vous déboulez chez moi je paie mes
impôts
donc je vous interdit de venir ici me
traiter comme si j'étais l'aîné écoutez
moi tiens ce type là n'étant rien je
répète pour que ce soit clair il n'est
en rien j'étais en rien mon ami 0
loyauté très bien monsieur joyner
prouvez le